like basically what will happen is girl
come on the Pod say some wild then it
gets clipped goes viral I mean I don't
know what you thought was gonna happen
and and so like this one girl
um this guy on the panel wasn't even me
it was like everyone say their body
count three two one and his whole point
was that none of the girls were gonna
say it this girl said it okay now it was
like it was like four five but she's
Indian or something in her community
she wanted me to take the stream down
and I was like no I paid a producer it's
like you go through all this work to get
the panel together
threatened me with like the Indian Mafia
I don't know this is so very
intimidating yeah because she knows
where I live because it's like the
podcast so it's like yeah and then she
was just gonna wait with her Matthew
they never did it though